わーマックシェイクぷっちんプリン味いただきます
[音楽]
世界で一番前堂々来たーー始めたと言って皆さんマクドナルドもシェイク期間限定
メニュー力あると思うんですけども今はこちらのマックシェイクのプッチンプリン味が
今期間限定でておりますやほんとねー
[音楽]
引くほど甘いそれから本当にマックシェイクの期間ってマジで全部美味しいんですよ
そしてなんと2020年5月の僅かからマックシェイクの新しい味が出ますこちら
ランプセグラムネ味でございます
いやいやもう絶対うまいじゃないですかそんなもう食べる前から上がってます
めちゃくちゃおいしいでもまだ発売前なので食べれないやることはただ一つこれしか
ないでしょう
つくりまし良いするものこちらラムネ農家市のメディアの相談のラムネマックシェイク
のバナーでございますいやなんかどう作ろうか考えたんですけどもうとりあえず基本的
なんかバニラなのかなっていうよそうです1
味にクセがないんでこれをベースに作っていきましょうどう作っていくかもなんかこれ
ところなら配合のレベルで一番おいしいところが食べが商品化されるのではないかと
いう意味でございますやなんかめっちゃ安易なことしてる鍋弱馬鹿なことしてるかも
しれませんけどこれが本当に本物なぜた同市な俺だけだけに読めちゃうよ
では早速作っていきましょうと言い会えず食べてみますか一回もと同じを知らないと
チャンドラーメディアずのシェイクができたりとかわかんないんでまず普通に食べて
みようと思います子供のこれ地域ばかりでにくって好きだったんですよなぜかになり
ます
うん
あーやっぱのこの味のシェイクは絶対おりますよそれはもちろんの味のシェイクなんと
かは勝手で発動前にたどり着かせたいというわけですに表のテーマは骨味見してみ
ましょう
いただきます
[音楽]
ん
第いってマックシェイクをこっちにマズルパターントラックシークとこっちゃまずい
パターンそして最後に両方バーゼルパターンで作ってみたいと思いますまずは佐久市
ています
ラメでを砕きましたおくなくのます一番大事ですいたがまあ結構準備したんで俺に[ __ ]
多いに越したことはないでしょうなるべくらー皆のパウダーを作るようにしたいと思い
ます
ウォッちずらぼ
さすがに多すぎる気がしますがまあこれがギャルに越したことはないでしょ
この頃のパウダーでしていきたいとおもいますいきます
ラーメンネットメンズラインだな
[音楽]
でもすごい一瞬で綺麗なこの版やったのすげー
うわあああああ
ウズあんまってクラスフレグランスためてご覧ください完全な粉になりましたこれを
もう政府に打ち込んでます食べてみましょうこれで完成現在そのしまるで
ま寿司御膳分します
うえはいはい第 s サイズってこんなものですねこれにあったり男中によってむずく
ねこれなかなか
までも入れれば入れること多分ダメでかわすと思うんで
おっ
インクが光ってる奴はよしよしいいんじゃないしたこれで計混ぜていいんでしょうか
ええええええ
いいがつかインパルぽいよファニングもなんか ea 完成貼っちゃってまあ
いやもっといければこれだろあああ
ああああああああ
いやー黙れお前何でしょうができる
でも意外と大丈夫そうか前世が原形を留めた気がしますねこれで買ったかこれでこんな
的で無理かなと思ったんですけど意外とすんなりと受け入れられてくれますつっ
寒ざらしでそうですけどまぁこれぐらいだった組んで可愛いもんでしょ
というわけでできましたマックシェイクラムネ味でございます
まあまずし殺菌ですねこれでもめっちゃメーカーでたらどうしよう
さっそく飲んでみたいと思いますいただきます
ザラザラずこれウは三役だザラザラするわいや何カッ
違うなんて美味しいですよキャップずで美味しいですけどめっちゃ細い優秀方をやって
ますこんな感じ
ラムネのシェイクってするって飲めるから持ち味なのに細かいラメでな減るわけで
台無しになってますうんうん
次行きましょ作戦2で次はもうめっちゃ親父なんですけども万事な生育の中にをラムに
を入れちゃうっていうシンプルな感じでね言ったバカっぽく見えるんですけども
に入ってこういうのねか
制裁することがあると思うんです
いいでしょうか
うっかりマジます
女子いい感じじゃないでしょうかしっかりと混ざったので遊ぶフランス飲んでいきたい
と思いますだ不安なのがそしていく独特のドローンカーンが線がたくさん加入したこと
によってちょっと薄なってですよね
シェイクというかどうかっていう問題ですねほドロドロのスムーズみたいなところまで
をしておりますいただきます
ご覧いただきます
茶名はビビるクリームソーダの一番美味しい時期ですこれちょうどアイスも時って民間
でから待ってるところ
仏山市た
違うんですよこれじゃないんで僕のしたいのはただのクリームソーダ
それも結構石やつ最悪です今度したくないですというで最後のプラン3に移りましょう
いきたいを混ぜてもなんかだねこのだけ混ぜてもざらすすなわち
両方たしてみればあればいいんまずあの子なぁこれも固形なんで何がどうあってもその
がは政府によることは深場なんですよこれはめっちゃ好きーさんあったらまず溶かす
作業から入りますよこれタダとかしても結局熱が冷めるとまた固まっ積んでお礼を編む
に良い得てすぐに成分とだしております
いいんじゃないでしょうかあぁなんか目
さあバグってるが大丈夫かはいこれをねせることによって水分を維持されつつ
な胸が熱で溶けてめちゃくちゃいい感じにしていくと混ざることができると思いました
けど大ショッカー
あちゃんと業ラブねえこれで解けるとさっきの者伊勢時間はなくなるんです
例えばしていく質の担保される完璧です
[音楽]
持っていた
強いば月ないです
分かっ待ってん
やばいやばい良い
今すごいハーバーになってたけどが完璧だといった時である
紙ではい生後で成功ですご覧くださいもう左右左右でせ masa u
はいオッケー
一発
竜 a 松江ねーな火傷したくないでこれを
どうしましょうねこんなついのシェイクを目指していく溶けちゃうて b お店の儲け
凍らせればいいと思うんでウエストのシェイプ地区は普通の遺物かいますってこんな辺
ちょっとあっついんですけどかなんとか
なってくださいメッシー時ならめでを入れます
ok で今冷たいが脱衣の戦ってる最中んですけどそこをしっかりところ乱戦ですって
おりますはいこれちょっと一瞬とボトルなんですけどこれ仕方ないですねなぜなら熱い
ものと冷たいものが混ざってるね今ちょうど h 依存になってしまいました
ですがこれを再びテイクの幼児に戻してはいはいはいはい
いたを捨て
冷やすこと約1時間
というわけで大変お待たせいたしました1時間以上待ちました
髪がちょっとすごい気になるのよ
まあいつも凍ってはいますね配管ペティ
なのでしょうかちょっと勝つことにしすぎましたねちょっととカセイケっぽくなると
待ちましょう
me
よしかなり溶けてきましたというわけでこっちらがマックシェイクラムネ味でござい
ます
ようやくたどり着きましたいやー長かってここまで行くとなく挑戦を繰り返しようやく
完成したら胸やツイッター増加し
20may 発売のラムネ味に近いことでしょう
[音楽]
だけじゃん
ん
うん
施工だ
me
えさ板
げっキャビックんですねっ
[音楽]
ん
木目ってナムに当てさんねっ
炉棟はじゅんやは理想でてないですよねっ
あっあすごいなちゃんと成功したは人間やれば出来るんじゃん戻るかもちゃんと
シェイクのままだしてもう本当に完璧にシェイクにラムネを足すことができましたね
やって成功すると思ってなかったから落ちを考えてないんだよな
なんか
[音楽]
voodoo